[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous j'espère que vous avez
encore un petit peu de ressources je
sais bien que là c'est la fin de la
journée c'est pas évident pour passer
surtout après des interventions aussi
brillante que mes collègues tout à
l'heure donc je vais vous parler de deux
tease mais bien sûr mais avant de
commencer j'aimerais vous donner une
information vraiment importante c'est
que je ne suis pas autiste
alors il ya des gens parmi vous qui vont
peut-être se dire mais pourquoi est ce
qu elle le dit quand même ça se voit
c'est pas très utile et ben en fait si
je trouve utile de le dire parce que
l'autisme au premier coup d'oeil ça se
voit pas tous les jours parfois même
c'est même assez fréquent que ça ne se
voit pas il peut y avoir des personnes
que l'on va trouver un petit peu bizarre
un petit peu étrange mais la plupart du
temps les difficultés des personnes
autistes sont très subtiles et beaucoup
d'entre elles cachent finalement leur
leurs difficultés et aujourd'hui ce que
j'aimerais vous faire découvrir ce sont
les deux facettes de l'autisme que sont
le handicap invisible d'un côté et des
compétences inexploitées de l'autre
alors on a du mal à comprendre parfois
ou à se rendre compte qu'on a une
personne autiste en face de nous parce
qu'il ya beaucoup d'idées reçues qui ont
été véhiculées autour de l'autisme
depuis plusieurs années par les médias
par le cinéma et notamment pour certains
si en face de soi on a une personne qui
parle qui travaillent qui est en couple
les gens vont se dire ah non c'est pas
possible cette personne n'est pas
autiste
alors ya peut-être des gens parmi vous
qui ont vu ou au moins entendu parler du
film rain man qui est assez vieux pour
certains mais pourtant c'est un film qui
pour moi a largement contribué à
à ce genre de d'image sur l'autisme
enfin la personne dans sa bulle qui
rentre jamais en interaction donc parler
et être autiste c'est finalement assez
contradictoire pour certains pour
d'autres selon les médias que vous avez
pu voir l'autisme c'est finalement les
personnes qui ont des compétences
exceptionnelles
complètement hors norme c'est le cas de
daniel tammet est par exemple qui est un
auteur de plusieurs ouvrages qui parlent
des langues et parmi ces dix langues en
fait il a appris de l'islande est tout
seul en une semaine
et puis ce qu'il est aussi capable de
faire c'est pendant cinq heures ils
peuvent vous réciter les 22 1514
premières décimales de la lettre pin fin
de nombreuses vies pardon sans se
tromper bien sûr un autre personnage
assez connu c'est stéphane wilshire
qu'on appelle aussi parfois l'homme
caméra parce qu'en fait c'est un
monsieur continent le survol d'une ville
en hélicoptère
ensuite il se met à dessiner de tête
évidemment sans photo la ville qu'il a
survolé pendant trente quarante cinq
minutes et avec une des détails d'une
précision extrême c'est au nombre
d'arbres près en au nombre de fenêtres
prêtes
alors évidemment l'autisme c'est des
personnes effectivement qui qui ont
parfois qui ne parlent pas qu'ils ont
besoin d' aide de la part des éducateurs
pour leurs gestes de la vie quotidienne
c'est aussi à l'autre extrémité des
personnes aussi exceptionnel que
stéphane mouche ailleurs ou ou daniel
tammet tu es moi je voudrais vous parler
de toutes les autres personnes autistes
qui finalement se fondre dans la masse
et dont les difficultés autant que les
compétences ne se voit pas au premier
coup d'oeil
alors je voudrais en parler pour deux
raisons la première c'est que mon
expérience m'a amené à voir assez vite
que sont des personnes que la société a
un rendu très vulnérable parce qu'elle
les a malmenés et pas plus tard que
mercredi j'ai fait la connaissance d'un
jeune homme qui rend dans le service et
qui
finalement on a tellement parlé avec les
autres qui refuse de sortir de chez lui
il reste tout le temps à la maison part
quelques exceptions
il veut plus travailler c'est plus
possible est ce qu'il m'a dit c'est vous
savez je me sens vraiment fragile et je
trouve que l'environnement est trop rude
pour ça c'est la première raison est la
deuxième on le sait pas toujours mais
l'autisme c'est très fréquent
ça touche 1% de la population à peu près
selon les études ce qui fait que dans
cette salle il ya peut-être une personne
autiste statistiquement parlant ou que
finalement ça nous touche de près voire
de très près pour certains ou d'un peu
plus loin mais en tout cas ça concerne
vraiment tout le monde alors je n'aurai
pas la prétention moi de dire que je
sais ce que c'est que vivre l'autisme je
voulais dire je ne le suis pas par
contre j'ai travaillé pendant près de 10
ans fin pendant plus de 10 ans 20 ans
auprès de ces personnes et je pense
quand même pouvoir me faire le témoin de
leurs compétences et aussi de leurs
difficultés alors l'autisme dans les
grandes lignes
c'est quoi c'est ce qu'on appelle les
troubles de la communication sociale
je vais vous donner des exemples des
intérêts restreints et stéréotypé et des
particularités sensorielle alors
évidemment je vais pas rentrer dans le
détail de ces trois grandes catégories
de symptômes mais je vais vous donner
quelques exemples qui illustrent
finalement à quel point ces personnes
sont mal comprises le premier point
concerne la communication sociale
notamment souvent ce qu'on se dit c'est
que encore une fois un les autistes
ils n'aiment pas communiquer ils
préfèrent rester dans leur bulle
ils veulent pas se faire des amis etc
alors oui il ya beaucoup de personnes
autistes qui apprécient de rester seul
deux long moment pour autant parmi
toutes les personnes que je rencontre à
mon travail à chaque fois quand elles
arrivent chez nous elle nous demande pas
la première demande qu'elles ont c'est
soit la première demande ou alors c'est
la seule même c'est qu'on leur apprenne
à se faire des amis donc on voit bien à
quel point elles sont un intérêt pour
les autres sauf que beaucoup de
difficultés les amène à être très très
maladroite socialement le premier
exemple c'est ce qu'on appelle la pensée
libérale
les personnes autistes ans quand même
tendance à prendre les choses au pied de
la lettre
et alors quand à cela on ajoute ce qui
est aussi fréquent dans l'autisme une
pensée en images ça peut donner des
choses assez surprenante de ce type là
évidemment c'est un exemple un peu
humoristique papa où es tu je suis dans
un bar ou dans un café si tu préfères ou
alors papa me dit que ses collègues le
rajout lui casse les pieds donc on peut
imaginer des gens qui pensent ou des
personnes autistes qui pensent que que
ça c'est très littérale cette pensée
libérale elle peut amener à des
situations vraiment très très cocasse
c'est le cas de paul qui travaille dans
un supermarché et qui a interpellé par
une dame en pâte qui veut acheter un
réveil puisqu'il ya en rayon
électroménager et donc elle arrive avec
son réveil est ce qu'elle lui dise et
ben expliquez-moi comment je fais pour
me réveiller le matin pour les super
surpris du tout comment on peut poser
une question pareille
pour lui c'est évident mais il ya qu'à
ouvrir les yeux c'est un peu la question
qu'elle a posée quand même sauf que il y
avait un sous-entendu c'est à dire on
peut pas s'arrêter à cette compréhension
littérale elle ce qu'elle voulait elle
avait le réveil dans les mains ce
qu'elle s'attendait c'est d'avoir des
explications
en fait sur le fonctionnement du réveil
évidemment il n'a pas du tout entendu de
cette manière là c'est alex aussi qu'il
ya un jeune adolescent qui lui veut
prendre son goûter en fait dans le salon
donc il a un plateau il ya tous ont
goûté dessus et finalement sa mère lui
dit une fois que tu as fini du goûter du
débarras son plateau et tu vas le ranger
dans la cuisine pas de souci c'est pas
du tout en haillons rebelles il fait ce
que sa mère a dit une fois qu'il avait
terminé son goûter évident le plateau
mais il le vide sur la table du salon
et il va ranger le plateau dans la
cuisine pourquoi parce que sa mère a été
très précise sur l'endroit où l'orangé
mais elle n'a pas dit pourquoi elle n'a
pas précisé où il fallait se débarrasser
il fallait encore une fois comprendre
les sous-entendus un autre procès des
codes sociaux
c'est très très difficile et ça pose
beaucoup de problèmes aux personnes
autistes
c'est qu'au delà nous on les intègre de
façon très implicite mais la gestion de
l'implicite pour les autistes
c'est compliqué
ils ont toujours du mal à savoir ce
qu'ils peuvent dire ou ne pas dire à
quel moment parce que ça dépend toujours
du contexte
et quand vous n'avez pas intégré les
codes sociaux au mieux vous passer pour
quelqu'un de décaler au pire on passait
pour quelqu'un d'impoli est vraiment
insolent là c'est gaëtan qui doit avoir
un recrutement un entretien d'embauché
donc on le prépare avant quand même et
on lui dit surtout dans un entretien
d'embauché
tu ne répond pas au téléphone c'est pas
poli pas de problème
il comprend très très bien sauf que
pendant l'entretien
le patron lui reçoit un coup de fil et
lui il répond qu'est ce qu'il fait et
gaëtan c'est pas poli de répondre au
téléphone pendant un entretien de
recrutement
c'est aussi emilie qui vient d'intégrer
un nouveau travail et elle sait pas trop
en fait au moment de la pause déjeuner
si elle doit aller voir chaque collègue
individuellement pour leur souhaiter bon
appétit ou si elle peut le dire de façon
générale ça c'est pour les codes sociaux
l'autisme c'est aussi une tendance à se
perdre dans les détails ils ont du mal à
faire finalement le tri entre
l'essentiel et le superflu et qu'en plus
on as qui est encore aussi assez souvent
le cas des problèmes à se mettre à la
place des autres
ça donne la situation d'alain qui est
documentaliste aux impôts qui connaît
évidemment toutes les lois parker ça y'a
pas de soucis et puis on le met dans une
nouvelle tâche où il doit répondre au
téléphone en fait aux questions des
contribuables
sauf que rapidement les contribuables se
plaignent auprès de son supérieur
pourquoi parce qu'alain les noirs
littéralement dans une foule de détails
techniques et réglementaires les gens
comprennent pas donc ils demandent des
explications supplémentaires
et là il finit par dire de toute façon
nul n'est censé ignorer la loi et
raccroche
tout à leur joie nous a parlé des choix
et bah ça aussi ça pose problème
alors évidemment les choix on l'a vu
tout à l'heure c'est très grand choix du
genre
est-ce que je les pose ou pas ou des
choix un petit peu plus anodins encore
que vos rideaux ou mojito fraises
je ne sais pas trop mais en tout cas
quand on n'arrive pas à faire des choix
on n'avance pas en tout cas c'est le cas
de personnes autistes et c'est la
situation de max quand il est arrivé
dans notre service
il avait finalement jamais réussi à
trouver une orientation professionnelle
puisque c'est faire des choix parmi une
multitude de possibilités
donc il était très embêté pendant
finalement toute sa vie jusque là il
s'était fait traiter de fainéant par
tout le monde y compris par sa propre
famille qui comprenait pas pourquoi ils
pouvaient pas se positionner
c'est aussi un jeune qui passait son
temps en fait à manger des pizzas mais
midi et soir est toujours la même
quand on a creusé on s'est vite rendu
compte qu effectivement quand déjà il
fallait qu'ils choisissent un repas
fondre un type de plats différents etc
en plus quand on lui permettait de le
faire aller dans le magasin pour acheter
un paquet de riz par exemple quand vous
vous trouvez dans le rayon du riz va
vous avez je ne sais pas combien de
paquets de riz et bien c'est difficile
de choisir lequel c'est aussi un jeune
qui quand il doit se rendre dans un
endroit dans une pièce par exemple qui
comporte deux entrées et bien il sait
pas laquelle choisir
et il s'arrête tout net devant la la
salle tout à l'heure j'ai parlé des
intérêts restreints
en fait les personnes autistes ont donc
beaucoup d'intérêt en tout cas elles
vont se spécialiser en fait la raison un
domaine d'intérêt elles vont aller
jusqu'au bout des choses et elles vont
tout tout tout maîtrisé sur ce domaine
là alors c'est le cas de frédéric qui
lui un moment donné de son parcours
s'est retrouvé quasiment dans la rue
mais une fois qu'on a pu l'aider mieux
le comprendre il a remonté il a pu
reprendre des études
il vient d'obtenir un diplôme en fait
parce qu'il est passionné d'informatique
qu'il a réussi haut la main et de façon
très très brillante
et puis maintenant il poursuit il et il
entame là tout juste une formation
d'ingénieur en informatique qu'on pense
qu'il aura aucun problème pour à obtenir
alors souvent il se focalise sur un
sujet d'intérêt mais évidemment ils
peuvent passer d'un sujet à l'autre et
frédéric notamment lui à une période de
sa vie il s'est passionné pour la
génétique et à tel point que au moment
où on lui a fait son diagnostic il a
carrément enseigné en fête ou à prix aux
médecins psychiatres du service tout un
tas de d'informations au sujet de la
génétique de l'autisme tellement il
était passionné et doit être que le
médecin ne connaissais pas ce qui est
pas très très banal c'est aussi michel
qui elle pas résultat son diagnostic
s'est passionné pour l'autisme et à une
mémoire tellement prodigieuse qu'elle
est capable elle a d'ailleurs été
recrutés dans un dans un laboratoire de
recherche au canada qui est assez connu
dans le monde de l'autisme est en fait
elle aide les chercheurs parce que donc
elle lit énormément de choses énormément
d'articles scientifiques et elle est
capable avec sa mémoire de détecter la
moindre petite contradiction entre les
différentes recherches ou une autre
personne qui est qui est passionné par
le liban et puis finalement qui alors
bien que très embêté dans les relations
sociales ont dit très clairement qu'ils
pourraient très bien être guide au liban
même s'il ne vit pas une vie en france
tellement il connaît le pays sur le bout
des doigts
un autre point ce sont les
particularités sensorielle j'en ai parlé
tout à l'heure le monde physique est
absolument terrifiant pour les personnes
autistes qui peut vivre un véritable
enfer avec les odeurs les lumières le
mouvement les bruits etc
alors ça sera pas tout de suite on pas
souvent parce qu'en général les arrive à
trouver des stratégies de compensation
et puis elles font tout pour le cacher
de toute façon et puis quand c'est trop
on les voit plus parce que
elles partent elles vont se cacher pour
se protéger parce que ça peut
littéralement leur faire mal pour autant
ça permet aussi pour certains d'avoir
deux formidables compétences c'est le
cas d'eric qui lui est passionné de
moteur et il est aussi hyper sensible au
niveau auditifs et ben c'est quelqu'un
qui est capable d'anticiper sur des mots
des pannes
parce que à l'oreille il arrive tout de
suite à détecter si un moteur ne
fonctionne pas comme il devrait
emilie est là les passionnés
d'horlogerie et elle est hyper sensible
sur le plan visuel
donc on l'a incitée quand même à
exploiter ce talent dans le cadre du
travail
et quand elle a entamé un stage chez un
horloger elle s'est montré tellement
brillante et tellement talentueuse que
l'horloger c'est d'y bâtir je vais lui
donner de montre que personne dans le
service n'a jamais réussi à réparer
donc il donne la montre évidemment elle
trouve la peine tout de suite grâce à
son hypersensibilité visuel en fait
c'était un micro mécanismes et qui était
sorti fun micro pièce qui était sorti de
son mécanisme et qui empêchaient la
montre de fonctionner il y avait bien
qu'une personne autiste pour pouvoir
détecter ce genre de panne ou clerc qui
elle est hypersensible son plan le fac
tiff et qui a pu devenir n'est donc la
personne qu'ils quitteraient les parfums
tous ces exemples là pour vous montrer
finalement à quel point leur univers est
très différent du nôtre et que même si
toutes ces particularités les gêne
beaucoup au quotidien ça leur permet et
à mon sens ça leur a permis finalement
de développer des qualités
qu'on est parfois très très loin de
pouvoir égaler et justement après plus
de dix ans de l'accompagnement de ces
personnes je peux vraiment témoigner que
l'autisme
ça correspond enfin sept cent des
personnes qui sont très fiables qui sont
tenaces qui sont perfectionnistes
elles vont vraiment jusqu'au bout des
choses et ne supporte pas de s'arrêter
tant qu'elles n'ont pas été au bout de
quelque chose et elle ont horreur de
l'approximation donc au travail ça peut
être des personnes avec de formidables
atouts
elles sont profondément honnête les ont
un sens de la justice aiguë peut-être un
peu trop parfois mais c'est une qualité
qui peut qui peuvent nous manquer leur
particularité les amène aussi à trouver
souvent des solutions très original que
nous aimons serait pas capable de
détecter avec un fonctionnement qui est
le nôtre et un dernier point qui est un
peu moins connus mais que je trouve
enfin voilà qui moi m'a sauté aux jeux
aux yeux assez rapidement c'est leur
humour
elles ont du mal à comprendre l'humour d
autres par contre elle
elles peuvent être très drôle et
notamment l ont découvert un nouveau
syndrome en fait installer le syndrome
neurotypiques alors là il faut que je
vous en dise quelques mots quand même
parce que je vous disais l'autisme c'est
courant c'est un pour cent de la
population
le syndrome d'euros typique ça l'est
encore plus puisque ça correspond aux 99
autres pour cent de la population
donc si jamais vous vous retrouvez en
fait dans les particularités du syndrome
neurotypiques c'est normal puisque si
vous n'êtes pas autiste vous êtes
neurotypiques alors les autistes nous
explique ce que c'est que ce fameux
syndrome neurotypiques donc finalement
notre fonctionnement à nous pour eux les
neurotypiques ont finalement un souci de
préoccupation sociale un peu excessif
pour certains des délires de supériorité
et puis surtout l'obsession de
conformité il faut rentrer dans le moule
faire comme tout le monde ça c'est
vraiment le gros problème des
neurotypiques dans les symptômes ce
qu'on peut voir c'est que c'est des gens
qui ont tendance à considérer que
finalement leur expérience du monde et
soit la seule soit la seule qui soit
bonne des personnes qui ont vraiment du
mal à rester tout seul
ça c'est vraiment compliqué pour eux des
gens qui ont du mal avec la différence
avec les autres guillaume l'a expliqué
tout à l'heure elle un peu l'illustré et
puis surtout les neurotypiques ont quand
même beaucoup plus souvent tendance à
mentir que les autistes
ils savent beaucoup mieux le faire alors
malheureusement pour nous le cerveau
nombre d'heureux typique ça se guérit
pas il n'y a absolument aucun remède
pour ça par contre on a craint une
petite lueur d'espoir c'est que les
autistes comme se sont rendu compte
d'une petite chose c'est que pour
certains certains neurotypiques arrive
quand même à surmonter leur handicap et
finalement parfois à rentrer en
interaction avec les personnes autistes
donc heureusement on est un peu sauvé
pour conclure en fait ce que j'aimerais
avoir le message que j'aimerais faire
passer c'est que les personnes autistes
elle mérite vraiment largement qu'on
apprenne à les connaître
ce sont des personnes vraiment sensible
qui ont de grandes qualités humaines
morales et de formidables compétences à
on l'a vu et c'est sûr que si on
s'arrête à ce qu'on voit donc si on ne
va pas au delà des apparences finalement
on risque pas de s'en rendre compte et
pour moi d'essayer de les comprendre
un petit peu ne serait ce qu'un petit
peu et finalement de les prendre telles
qu'elles sont c'est déjà beaucoup les
aider et puis c'est surtout leur donner
toute la place qu'elle mérite finalement
autant que nous dans un monde qui qui
pour moi est finalement assez
impitoyable
voilà je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]